yeah but I also want to say to you that
you've really changed over the years
though in the Neyman transsexual noun
transvestite no no you in the 90th I
felt like you were difficult to reach
hmm and you became more human as like
now I can really genuinely say that
we're friends and that I love you before
I was intimidated by you and it was more
of an employer it boss a relationship
yeah and then it was you softened yeah
well I was young that was super young I
mean when I made it I was [ __ ] 20 I
was like the [ __ ] I don't say I was
the biggest star but I mean like at the
time yeah you and I mean like in like in
my team we're not my teens but in my
like all my 20s how old are you a 45 now
you're 45 no you have to understand
something I hit and I was on MTV when
MTV was the biggest thing in the world I
remember the biggest thing in the world
yeah you know what's the biggest thing
in the world Netflix now Game of Thrones
ok Game of Thrones I was like the Game
of Thrones back I know you were really
worried yeah it was like albums in
movies in HBO an empty mind I was
[ __ ] going insane and I grew up the
Philippines and you were huge there yeah
so was yeah so it was it was a [ __ ]
amazing time that's part of the reason
why I'm doing my documentary you know
I'm showing I have all that footage yeah
from that era because that was before
the internet and that was before and the
younger generation doesn't really know
yeah like my friend Joey who's editing
this one this other document his
girlfriend she's Asian she's cool it's
Halle she's awesome
but she just Joey tries to tell her like
dude you don't understand like Pauly
Shore at the time was like the [ __ ]
and she's like I don't get it yeah your
name age is like I don't get it and then
he'll show like stuff and she'll be like
I really still don't get it
no no she'll be like she'll be like wow
I didn't believe that or whatever
because MTV then was just the coolest
thing yeah what do you think about TV
now do you think it's just I don't watch
him yeah yeah garbage but even when I
opened for you the first time in Vegas
at the Riv Riviera
was at the top of the rib it was at 97
yeah yeah 90s 97 and it was 5000 seats a
show I mean it was packed
yeah and and then you would go to his
penthouse
remember the marble and the grand piano
overlooking via me it was like because
I'm I was waiting tables that I didn't
know anything hmm I'm from San Diego I
don't know nothing and to see that and I
remember Kevin was on your sitcom Kevin
Westman yeah Wiseman yeah Kevin meeting
him your mom was there and that was the
night the first time I ever opened for
you where she made me a regular it was a
life-changing event for me because she
just walked up his mom and goes you're a
regular at both of my clumps and it was
I literally teared up I mean I could I
didn't know what to say and then when I
met went back to San Diego everyone
hated me yeah because of the fact that I
had only been doing comedy for like a
year and I got plucked out by the shores
and so there was I think a little
jealousy yeah and I was a little cocky
because I was you know vetted by you
mean the family
[Music]